- Hey hey girlfriend, what's up?
You wanna straw?
- No, don't need one.
- Sucks to suck sweetheart.
Hi I'm Straw.
Did you know 500 million me
are used in the US per day?
Per day, Sheila, per day!
I'm too small for the recycling machine,
so I can't get recycled.
(slurps)
- Hey-ey-ey-ey, I'm Coffee Cup.
Did you know that an
estimated 60 billion of me
end up in landfills across the US?
The US each year.
(laughs)
They don't know what to do with me.
At least I'm not as bad as styrofoam.
(laughs)
- You actually kinda are.
- Hey you might think I
have it all, you know,
because I'm made of paper, and
I'm recyclable, but I'm not.
Only my lid and my sleeve are recyclable
because baby, the inside
of me is all plastic.
Shhh! Don't tell anybody,
but tell everyone.
Don't tell anybody but tell people
because they're not recycling me right.
- Hi, I'm Plastic Bag.
(scoffs)
Every year, more than a trillion of me
are used and thrown away.
Every year, a trillion.
I mean I'm fun, listen
to me, listen to me.
Each year 8 million tons of
plastic end up in the ocean.
(blows raspberry)
I love the ocean.
I hope a fish eats me, so I
end up on your dinner table.
- Hello, my name is Water Bottle.
You look very thirsty, are you dehydrated.
- It's a hot day, so I
could use some water.
- I'm easily accessible, and
I'm not just saying that.
You know globally,
you humans buy a million
of me each minute.
- Really?
- One minute (jibberish) each minute.
And guess what?
Only nine percent of the
plastic produced gets recycled.
(speaks foreign language)
We plastics take 400 years to break down.
You can never get rid of me, baby.
(cackles)
- Hi, I'm Take Out.
If I'm covered in food grease,
even when you try to recycle me,
I just end up in a landfill.
- What do you want me to do about it?
- Wash me out.
Look at this Jess; you can't recycle this.
You know, the average American
makes about 4.4 pounds of trash a day.
They always say reduce, reuse, recycle,
but don't forget about the reduce.
Reduce is important.
- Guess what, I'm going on
a vacation to the Galapagos.
(laughs)
I hope I end up in a sea turtle's nose.
(slurps)
(rhythmic music)